[Music]
okay i'm very pleased and very proud to
introduce you
professor joshua bianchio
everyone know him but
he is
the full professor at the university
montreal
scientific
director but also the founder of the
mila academic institute
he is also
the
scientific director of evado that
everyone knows
very well because it is under the
canadian part of dil
and
he is working very deeply at the earth
of the ai ecosystem at montreal
he
he he was and he is recognized as one of
our best worldwide
leading expert in artificial
intelligence and he is the recipient
of the
2018 touring award for his popular work
on deep learning
and
as you know the torino award is a kind
of nobel prize in computer science
so now we are very pleased to have a
keynote of joshua bengio on
g-flow nets for generative active
learning
the floor is your joshua
bonjour hello everyone uh it's good to
be uh with you even though it's at a
distance
can you please
show the slides
all right
so
today i'm going to tell you about some
really recent work uh that i'm very
excited about
um
it's a bit technical but i'll try to
give you sort of a high-level picture of
how this is different from the
usual way that we've been using machine
learning in
typical applications
um
and uh it it has to do with many
concepts uh as you see in the title it
has to do with uh generated models it
has to do with active learning
the terms the term g flow nets comes
from generative flow networks and i'll
explain that later
next slide
okay so so first
the
active learning scenario um is is quite
different from the usual machine
learning scenario in the sense that
instead of having a fixed data set
that uh we're given once and for all and
then we build a system and then we can
deploy it
um
we're going to allow the learning system
to
uh ask questions uh in other words to
participate in uh what example we should
collect
so this is the idea of active learning
um
and it has been proposed a long time ago
uh
when
we
were able to have a large quantity of
unlabeled images for example and
it was expensive to label so it would
use the computer
to propose which
examples should be labeled
now uh with reinforcement learning
becoming really important part of
machine learning in the last decade
it's clear that we can do much better
than that it's not just
which
example that exists in some database
should be labeled but also even like
what to do uh what example like we could
generate an image for example to be
labeled right so you can think of a a
child that is deciding to explore in a
particular direction because uh they
find that they might they might learn
more in some in some with some new toy
or something like this so this is all
active learning
um but it it really uh changes the game
in terms of the way we think about
machine learning in many ways
uh so for example one aspect is that
instead of having this fixed data set
the data set keeps growing
and in addition the data coming from
that data set is
not always of the same nature so if you
think again about the child moving from
uh one room to the next and then
getting bored with the toys that they uh
have played with
um the distribution of the examples that
the child sees keeps changing so so this
is a really a major challenge
and you can think of the
this actually like the child or like the
scientist who's designing experiments
and and in fact uh i'll be uh you know
i'm working on applications of these
kinds of methods
for discovery uh of new materials of new
drugs and so on where the machine
learning system can propose experiments
like what new molecule to try and what
kind of experiment should we do and then
collect the data and that you know gives
us more data retrain the system produce
more questions and so on okay so there's
this iterative interactive system
next slide
now what could we use this for uh
many things um but i'm going to focus uh
mostly on
the
application that some people call black
box optimization but i would like to
rename it black box exploration
so the the reason we talked about a
black box
is because
the
there's a system
that we
don't know precisely like that we don't
have math or equation that says what's
going on so you can think of a plant
you can think of an experimental
benchmark
um and you can now that system you can
think of as a function uh we call we're
going to call it an oracle
and that function takes inputs and the
machine learning system produces these
inputs it it's the questions like what
molecule should i try
or what setting of my plant
should i try and then the function
produces outputs so you know x is the
input y is the output
um
and
we
might be interested in a particular
output that is a quantity
we're trying to maximize so you can
think of uh how well is your plant going
or how good is that molecule for the
task you want to do or how good is this
material
so this is this is a problem where
you're trying to optimize something like
you're trying to find
a drug that
binds uh well to the target
uh or you're trying to find a setting of
your plant that produces
a
good quality output and you haven't
where to measure that scalar that you
know
tells you how good it is
so so you can think of this as a black
box because we don't know like we don't
have a good mathematical model of what's
going on inside but we can query it
okay um and uh what sort of queries
should we do
well uh
we would like to find
a configuration of the input that gives
us a high value of y so we're looking
for good molecules or good settings of
the plant
[Music]
so
in a way we can think of this as an
optimization problem but i'm going to
say we should also think of it as an
exploration problem because we don't
know where to look
right so so there's the question of
exploring the space
and getting information about this black
box in some sense
so
one thing the machine learning system
might do is uh
approximate this black box by training a
supervised learner that approximates it
but but we want the approximation to be
good in many places and so
we we need to
find kind of representative uh
configurations of the input and and like
randomly choosing the x's
is probably not a good idea think about
the scientists do they do random
experiments
like uniformly try combinations of
things no they plan their experiments uh
and most
you know random experiments would be
like uninteresting
uh again going back to the child they
they don't do run the movements with
their hands they actually
i mean initially that might they might
do but eventually they they have very
purposeful
uh
movements that that aim at trying
something new for example that they
might learn from
now in a
in many experimental setups where we
have this black box actually this black
box can tell us the answers
to many questions at the same time so if
i'm going to
use a biological or chemical
assay to evaluate different molecules i
can probably do 10 at a time or even a
thousand at the time or even in you know
synthetic biology i can do
a million at the time okay so i can
generate a lot of data at a time that
means
i'm not allowed to i can ask like a
thousand different questions uh if i'm
going to allow myself to ask the oracle
many things i'd like those things to be
diverse not the same question repeated
over and over because i don't learn any
information so there's a notion of
information there that is really at the
heart of all this next slide
right
so let me recap what classical active
learning is
uh also now called pool based activa so
so that's the scenario i was telling you
earlier where
there is already a fixed list of
questions so think of a bunch of images
that we have collected from the internet
and um and we should choose with active
learning which of these images in this
long list
um we're gonna ask a human being to
label
okay so that's like one way to think
about this setup
and
so the oracle here is the human the
human is going to give us
an answer
and
the question
now is how should we choose those
examples to label
and the idea that i mentioned earlier
about kind of information gathering is
really what's behind
a lot of the algorithms
so a heuristic way to think about this
is
um we're going to build a model that
predicts what the human is going to uh
produce but it's going to be a
probabilistic model it's a model that
produces not just an answer like it's
it's a cap but also oh well
it's a cat and i'm pretty sure it's a
cat like 90 or i'm not so sure maybe you
know 60 it's a cat and
and 40 it's a dog
so
so now we have this this measure of
uncertainty and the idea that many
people have been using is
let's
um pick
examples to label that are more
uncertain that means there's more
entropy more information to be gained by
asking for instance
now
this you know so there was the good old
days of active learning where uh we were
trying to solve this uh labeling problem
but what if
um
instead of having this list of
pre-existing images that you could label
you could
ask for any
image you could make up a new picture
for example and ask what is in the image
and in the case of my example with
molecules
that's basically what we can do right
instead of using a fixed list of
molecules
uh i mean the list isn't you know can't
be if we use a fixed list we have
databases for example like the zinc
database it has a few million molecules
or i guess maybe a couple of hundred
millions um
but still it's a tiny fraction of the
space of all molecules uh and especially
i mean even if i restrict myself to
small molecules it could be a drug
there's like 10 to the 60 different
possible
such molecules so
um
we would really have to like to have
more freedom
and pick
from all the possible ones and so
how are we going to solve this problem
next slide
right so what we're going to do
is we're going to use a giant model and
you probably already know
there's been a lot of progress in deep
learning
um to
train neural nets that can do not just
like classification but actually
synthesize new images generate images
dream up new things according to a
distribution that's
the the uh learned from using data for
example existing images
so so we have this technology for
training a generative model and maybe we
can like tweak that kind of uh
generative model so that it learns to
produce good questions in other words
questions that it's going to give us
more information
all right
so
um
this is interesting because now
the exploration that the active learner
is allowed to do is a little bit like
the scientists i mean they can invent
new molecules right not just take from
the fixed list
so how are we going to do that um so in
the picture here i'm trying to kind of
uh
cartoon what is going on what are the
different pieces here on the right hand
side you see the the the the oracle the
real world uh setup the the bench
um the the uh
the environment uh that we're allowed to
query
um and we're getting data from it based
on the questions we're asking
um
and
then we're going to use that data
in order to
maybe create a kind of model of what's
going on and also of a kind of score for
uh what would be a good question and
then we're going to generate questions
that have a high score
let's go into a bit more detail of that
next slide
okay so so this is a a fuller picture of
what we're trying to do and
it's it's um it's connected to uh ways
of thinking in reinforcement learning
where you think about how agents
can learn about their environment and
learn to do tasks and so on
so on the right hand side we we have our
oracle it's the real world okay
and we're trying to build a machine
learning system that's going to interact
with that real world in order to
um
to build say a model of it all right so
in this simple scenario that i've been
discussing the model is just a function
that maps x to y
um
but we are allowed to ask questions like
which x uh
we're interested in and then the real
world is going to give us a y
and we're going to accumulate those data
in a data set okay up to now nothing
special
but the uh the thing in the middle is
the is the world model it's maybe our
prediction uh uh that we've trained
using that data so that's just
supervised learning as we acquire more
data we can like
fine-tune our model we train our model
um but the new thing is the thing on the
left so what's the thing on the left
thing on the left is the generative
model i was talking about it's the
imagination machine that's going to
produce
uh candidate experiments candidate
questions you know uh what image should
i label so it creates a new image
in the case of molecules it might
synthesize a new image virtually of
course
and then
once it's trained it's going to be used
to actually interact with the world and
propose these experiments
try this molecule try this molecule try
that molecule
and then of course that's going to give
us more data and we're going to be able
to update the world model
but the question is
how should we train that gender model
it's it's not doing exactly the same job
as uh you know things like gans that
i've been working on for a few years
generative adversarial networks or vaes
variational auto encoders and and other
standard alternative models
these standard generated models they
they're trying to kind of imitate
examples that they've seen like that you
you give them a bunch of images
and they're trying to generate other
images that kind of look like them
but here we're trying to do something
different uh we're trying to generate
images or molecules or settings of your
plants
that have some desirable properties
according to our model
so what's going to happen is we think of
it like more like a reinforcement
learning task the imagination machine
proposes something
and we're going to uh
check how good it is according to our
current model of the world
and if it's good we're going to reward
the the uh degenerative model so that it
continues doing things like this
and if the score is bad meaning you know
it's not an interesting molecule it's
one that doesn't really work where it
has wrong properties then it gets a a
bad reward like a negative reward and so
it learns not to do that again
all right so so that's the way we can
train that um
imagination machine
and the rest of my talk is going to be
focused on uh in part uh
going in more detail how we could do
that next slide
but but first
this picture uh with the different
components that i told you about um is
really something quite
general and and in fact inspired by
uh cognition about how humans
um learn and interact with their
environments and try things in their
environments
and try things in their head
so what was going on in the previous
slide is that the
the generative model the imagination
machine is
is imagining
candidate uh experiments
and not yet trying them out in the real
world just checking them with the model
you know would that be a good thing
according to the model
and then uh that's the way that
eventually it converges to
sort of a good policy for
what questions to actually ask in the
real world
so
so we know one
why we want these pieces uh
that i talked about in the previous
slide in in a general ai system that
interacts with their environment well
the world out there is dangerous okay
it's not a game it's not a video game
um
and so before you actually do an
experiment let's say with the new
molecule you might want to try it in
your head and see if it's not going to
blow up your lab or something
um of course the model in your head
isn't perfect but but at least you know
you can get some feedback as to whether
this looks good
so so we do that we plan in our head uh
and we kind of uh
especially think about dangerous things
uh quite a bit before we do them for
real
um
another reason for having the kind of
structure that i put there is
we can separate
the the machinery that like
has the intuition about
solutions to problems which is the
imagination machine
and the machinery that builds a model of
the world and a good thing with that is
that
that model of the world can be quite
structured right it can be decomposed
into parts
um which is the way for example
scientists decompose knowledge
i i i that's like another talk i could
give about uh how we should structure
our machine learning models to
um
break the knowledge into the right
pieces
uh which ideally correspond to causal
mechanisms like laws of physics
but that would be uh another time
um
the other um
uh
reason for this kind of system that i
showed
uh is that
you could in fact like a lot of um
uh
classical uh robotics and um
uh control systems
um don't
and then when when they want to take a
decision
they
um
they will kind of optimize for a good
plan
according to the model by searching in
the space of all experiments if you want
uh which one gives a high score
according to the model and of course
that's a that's a very expensive search
that's an exponentially expensive search
so what we're doing is we're replacing
that really expensive search
by a trained policy
by an agent that is the imagination
machine that in one shot like a neural
net that generates an image in one shot
produces a candidate solution
so
we compensate by
that by having
uh to train that policy that imagination
policy but we avoid a really expensive
uh search at run time so we're
converging runtime cost of planning
to
offline cost of training a policy that
proposes good things
and and in practice if like if you're a
human in in the jungle uh you probably
sometimes need to act quickly you don't
have time to plan so you just go for
your instinct and you do what's right
um so that's the idea of having uh
with what psychologists call system one
habitual routines that you don't need to
think just go and act
now
another reason for having a setup like
this is that
the actions in the real world could be
expensive like if i have to actually do
a chemical experiment
um it's going to take time it's going to
cost money and so on so before i do it i
better like practice in my mind right to
make sure that my plan is good
um and
um
and yeah so that's that's also the last
point that you you you can use this
internal
um search uh which is a kind of
computation you do in your head before
you act
to avoid danger um
uh to uh to train your your uh your
habitual system to do the right thing
and so on
um and so there's a lot of really
interesting connections to commission
but i'm going to move on uh
to the next slide
next slide please
no that's the previous one
yes
so briefly
uh one project that i'm working on that
uses these ideas
um
is of you know is is dear to my heart
because it really is trying to
uh do something about a huge challenge
for humanity that many people don't know
about
i mean we've been hit by the pandemic
and we kind of know how fragile we are
to infectious diseases but there are
other infectious diseases
for which
evolution can uh
produce mutations of the pathogens like
uh bacteria
uh that we we don't have tools to deal
with in particular um there's like new
variants of
of microbes that
our current antibiotics are kind of
drugs tend to deal with
and uh they're already hundreds of
thousands of people
dying each year because we don't have
those drugs but it's going to get worse
the prediction is that there's going to
be 10 million deaths per year by 2050 if
we don't find a solution to this problem
and it's going to cost
uh at least as much as the pandemic per
year to our economy so this is like
really really bad and it's coming to us
it's on the similar scale it's climate
change right so
um we need to develop pipelines for
discovering new drugs quickly as these
new variants emerge
and those those pipelines probably need
to be like automated as much as possible
using
ai to search uh quickly given like a
pathogen a a set of uh drugs that could
uh target it
next slide
next slide please
um there's another reason why i'm
interested in this that has to do more
with my basic research in
ai there is a really interesting
question
in um
deep learning which is how do we extend
it
to do
things that classically i you know aimed
to do like reasoning and handling
causality and so on
um and um
there is a an issue there that's like
more like a technical issue which is
uh given say an input
like a video uh how would the learner
form a
uh kind of causal explanation or an
explanatory story for what is going on a
high level abstract description of what
is going on
um and we don't have really good tools
for this
but it turns out that the same tools
that we can use for exploring
the space of molecules can potentially
be used to explore the space of graphs
that
contain basically an explanation for
some observations and we can use neural
nets to generate those graphs
so if you think about how humans think
um
it looks like it feels like what's
happening is when we are in front of a
problem or something we observe
um an explanation or a solution or some
high-level kind of uh verbalizable story
comes up to us it just pops up like if
it was produced by a jointed model where
we don't have access to like how we got
there and it's very fast
um then we can check it right um using
what we know but but uh
that generated model that imagination
machine really is the piece that we're
currently
missing to be able to do those things
next slide please
um
yeah i'm going to skip that one
next slide
all right so let me tell you about
the quest for information
for
um
[Music]
for the learner who's
has to decide what what example to use
right
and to
really wrap your mind around this
you have to
[Music]
distinguish two kinds of errors that the
learner can make
um
there is what we call epistemic
uncertainty and alliatoric uncertainty
so
alieter consumption is just a big word
to say noise it's the stuff that's
unpredictable
and you know going to do an experiment
where the result is unpredictable is not
very interesting
so i was uh
explaining that in the quest for
interesting examples
uh if er
we need to think about uh two kinds of
uncertainty so we're looking for
uncertainty but not any kind of
uncertainty right we're trying to reduce
our uncertainty and so
um
the uncertainty that the model has about
some something we care about like how
good a particular
molecule might be or something like this
um
there is a kind of uncertainty that can
be reduced by more data and then it's
worth to look at those examples this is
what we call epistemic uncertainties due
to our lack of knowledge
and then there's uncertainty that is
inherent to the real world that uh has
nothing to do with our knowledge or our
model
and it's just noise like we can't
there's nothing we can do about it and
in a way we'd like to get rid of that
and if we don't we don't want to go to
places that are noisy we want to go to
places where we lack knowledge okay so
we need to make that distinction
um next slide
next slide please all right
um so so there's a whole literature in
machine learning
to think about epistemic uncertainty
and uh a lot of that
it really
is anchored in uh bayesian statistics in
beijing machine learning and the reason
is that
what what the bayesian approach to
machine learning does is instead of
producing a single answer to a question
it produces all the possible answers uh
that are compatible with the data
and with our prior
knowledge so this is called the beijing
posterior
in the figure uh we can illustrate this
so
in in um
dotted is the true function we're trying
to figure out
and we're trying to maximize it um in
blue
the blue uh
line the blue curve is
our current best guess
right so it's not quite right but it
goes through the data points that are in
red
and then there is the sausage in in blue
right so what that sausage is is the um
the region of uncertainty that the
learner has
in other words it thinks that the right
answer could be anywhere in that sausage
it could be a function that goes
anywhere in that sausage
and it's a sausage because of the
training points there's a constriction
because we kind of know the answer there
right so so the the pale blue here
indicates our epistemic uncertainty
and we can use that in order to choose
examples that have a high epistemic
instrument
next slide
all right now that we can compute the
thing we care about like a mod of
uncertainty or something like this
um the problem is how we gonna train our
genital model
to
uh produce examples that are gonna bring
us a lot of information so
whatever the way we compute it let's
let's call this function that measures
how much information we think we're
going to gain from an example r for
reward r of x so x is a say a molecule
or an experiment we could do
and and using our model and our like
maybe bayesian approach we can come up
with a heuristic that tells us how much
information we think we will get if we
do the experiment x
so we got this reward function
um and what we'd like is a generative
model
that explores the world uh but
especially in places where the reward is
higher
so
this is different from normal uh
reinforcement learning which tries to
fund the experiment uh gives you the
maximum reward and the reason we want to
do this is we're
interested in having a diverse set of
solutions not just one experiment but
like think about many experiments we
could do
um and there are a lot of good reasons
for doing this for example in the case
of molecules
um
the
assay we're going to do is is not the
whole story like it it's it's going to
be maybe uh a cheap experiment on single
cells but at the end of the day we're
going to try to
do a clinical trial on humans and
and so the initial oracle might not be
perfect
and so we want to not just come up with
one solution that eventually ends up not
being right but a a bag of good
solutions that we're going to be able to
try later with the more expensive
um
site so so often we are in these
situations where we're not looking just
for one good thing but a bunch of
potentially good things
uh so so that's the idea here uh that's
why we are looking for adjacent models
that outputs
uh x's
experiments with a probability
p pt here
proportional to
our reward function so i said
proportional because the reward function
usually is not a density function so
it's not normalized and there's there is
this
unknown normalization constant that is
intractable to compute because the
number of possible experiments is
exponentially large
so the traditional way of doing this is
monte carlo mark of chain methods
unfortunately these methods
although they work quite well in sort of
low dimensional settings
and in in the kind of ai applications
uh they're not that great
uh they just take too much time to find
good samples or
even don't find such
diverse set of samples
so why why is it so let me explain
quickly what these mcmc methods do they
start from a solution and then they make
small random moves around it and then do
it again and again and again and and
they they keep the moves that um that
look good according to the energy
function to the uh reward function
um and and that allows to explore around
a mode like a you know an area where uh
there are lots of good solutions but if
if there's another very different type
of solution a different mode
it's very difficult for these mcmc
methods to jump from one of those modes
to another mode
in fact it could be exponentially hard
so what we want to do with machine
learning is help those mcmc methods find
uh these other places that could be
interesting like a more diverse set of
solutions
um by looking at what has already been
obtained for example we found these
three regions where you have good
solutions these three modes of the
reward function
the machine learning system can
generalize and say oh maybe there's like
this
other place uh in the in the grid there
that we haven't visited and maybe
there's a kind of structure in the data
that we can guess
because of the data we've seen and so
let's try this other place right
um so so in this way machine learning
can bypass this sort of slow local
changes that the
monte carlo market chains are limited to
next slide
right
and so we
we invented a method that was in the
title of my talk but i won't have really
much time to go into details called
g-flow nance that's
trying to replace mcmc basically in
other words to but but it's it's using
machine learning so we're going to train
a
generative model that makes a sequence
of moves to construct a solution for
example if we're talking about these uh
molecules we're going to add one atom at
a time or something like this and and
it's going to do that according to a
stochastic policy so it can generate
many possible solutions but some
more than others
uh i mean some with more probability
than others and and we can train that
giant model
so that it samples in proportion to the
rewards
um and uh i won't really have time to go
into how we do this but we have um a
first technical report that is available
uh online with the archive here actually
the paper was just accepted to europe so
it's gonna be also presented at the
nearest conference
and i should probably
stop here i mean uh we can go directly
to one of the last slides where we show
experiments on molecules
uh go to next next next next
uh next up okay yeah just uh before just
before before
no
previous one
yeah so so we played with that algorithm
on on uh
the problem searching in molecular space
and uh we compare it with multi-color
markov chains with classical
reinforcement learning methods
and it it finds solutions faster but it
also finds a more diverse set of
solutions which was our initial goal so
we are very like excited about this
thing as a as a
tool that can be used in many settings
and not just for this problem that we've
been investigating all right i'm going
to stop here so we can
move to the last yeah thanks
[Applause]
and i'm happy to answer questions
i'm sure that there is a lot of
questions
did you have some questions
there is something that i have not
understood in the beginning of your talk
when you when you are showing the slide
with the three
world well the real world and the two
world models
yeah okay so the
real world does not change we are not
going to improve it that's right
so but then you improve you are
improving the bottom one the
the world the world model that's right
the model that is changing yeah okay the
real world doesn't change the world
model is improved
and then you have the word on the top
you have the world model which is used
for imagination for imagine imagine
experiments but this one has no arrow
going back to it
so it's never yeah it has it has so yes
it has
yes i i you see this loop in the kind of
purple
between
loop
that's right
that's right you're training yourself in
imagination that's how you train
yourself because i mean in principle you
could train it like
with interacting with the real world and
that's what a lot of classical
reinforcement learning does
uh so model-free reinforcement learning
as it's called
directly interacts with the environment
to learn the policy
but but that's dangerous right
you've got like a baby you know breaking
things
so um
it makes sense uh at least in some
settings to have a model based approach
where
the policy the imagination machine
interacts with a you know
in its head with a model and in a way
you can think of like planning where you
try things in your head
you come up with a policy and then you
apply it in the real world no no i
understand this but you are not putting
an arrow back from the updated world
model to the world model itself oh no
yeah yeah no yes of course uh you know
there would be too many arrows it's the
same thing you know this is t g plus one
and then you know okay yeah
thank you thank you it's very clear now
no problem
on the same slide you have an arrow that
is going down from the upper model to
the the the down yeah and it's labeled
learning uh the clarity of knowledge
that's right elaborate a little more
about that
sure yeah
so so think about the like classical ai
facts and rules and stuff
except we want to learn them
um so or think about like a you know the
laws of physics you have a bunch of
equations
uh that describe your model of how the
world works now instead of being
rules or
differential equations that are set up
by hand by
by scientists they're going to be
learned so we're going to have some
machinery uh i mean depending on the
application it could be very different
but
really you should think of the uh the
world model is declarative knowledge it
doesn't tell you how to act it it tells
you
um the dynamics of the world or like if
i do this this would be the consequence
and then that would be the consequence i
can run my differential equation or
whatever
um and i can you know given um a plan of
uh action this world model will tell me
how things will turn out like it can
unfold
you know it's it's a it's a proxy for
the real world so it it can pre you know
it can be like a pretend world uh real
world
uh so you can
do things in the in the world model and
see what the outcome would be
so it's called declarative because
ideally uh
you know that's the piece i didn't have
time to talk much about uh it's broken
down into pieces that are communicable
to humans for example
and um and we can easily add new pieces
uh fix some pieces without uh
interference with the other ones and
that's very different from the standard
machine learning that we have these days
where
you have uh catastrophic interference
between different pieces of knowledge so
if i
uh see uh you know some some new uh
tasks
it kind of uh is gonna hurt my
performance on other tasks
so
this is uh this is uh
why i think we want to
break the knowledge in the world model
into these
uh
what i would like to call causal
mechanisms that are independent in a
mathematical sense
meaning that i can change one and it
doesn't perturb the semantics of the
others
thank you very much i have another
question into so um
just as a parenthesis can will we be uh
um entitled to get the slides to to
have the correct reference to your paper
and the second question is when you
tried your your algorithm on on
so uh i mean you you were trying it on
the problem where there is a value
function
and
how does it work in terms of balancing
the traditional exploration exploitation
uh compromise in in searching new areas
versus getting the right
optimal optimal solution
right uh excellent question so first of
all the
uh uncertainty estimation i didn't talk
a lot about but uh there's a lot that's
going on there to help us deal with the
exploration exploitation uh
trade-off um
there is some work i didn't talk about
where where
we can use the
world model
to
pretend we're gonna do a series of
experiments
right
and and then we have to deliver okay we
have to like produce the final answer or
something like this
um
and so if you run that simulation in
your head i mean in the with the world
model
so now
you don't just do one interrogation with
the world model you you pretend it you
know that you're gonna ask things
and then you're gonna get answers it's
gonna increase your data set now it's a
fake data set it's this is in your head
right it's not with the real world but
you can you can play that game like in
meta learning where you you can simulate
what would happen if i was to ask
questions through the oracle i would get
answer
i would then retrain my world model with
that data
and i would get you know maybe less uh
uncertainty in some regions and i can
then ask more different questions and so
on
when you do these kind of simulations
you can then learn a policy
that's going to do the right trade-off
between exploration and exploitation
um you can learn the policy i mean that
it should learn that initially you
should explore a lot because it's all
right you can you can try uh different
things you you still have many rounds of
experiments you can do but when it's
your last experiment
um maybe you want to take the best
candidate the thing you think is really
the best and and put it there right uh
so complete exploitation and zero
exploration
um and you don't need to handcraft it
it's gonna come out from the
optimization because the right policy is
one that
you know uh
initially explores uh because that gives
you more information and then later
uh exploits uh
it it it's gonna be the optimal policy
is gonna be the one that does that now
this is what we're trying to do we don't
have any paper on this but it's
it's uh i think it's a natural thing to
do once you have a role model you can
play those games
hi just one question uh it looks like
some second show sampling problem
i would just want to know how do you
compare with standard techniques such as
krigging where you search for the
highest viability and then you sample
the new point so have you
tried to compare on very simple problem
yes actually
um so you can compare with uh kriging or
gaussian processors kind of very similar
and um so so let's see what are the
differences here so one big difference
is we have this generative model in in a
standard um bayesian optimization
setting
with say a gaussian process you would
um
you would do the optimization for
searching for the the next best thing to
to do
by trying a large number of things but
in in the low dimensional space like a
1d space that's fine
i can like grid the input
or 2g space it's still okay but if it's
a thousand dimensional space or a
million dimensional space i can't do
that right it doesn't make sense so
searching in the space for which
experiment to do is just too expensive
and that's why you need the genetic
model
right so so that's the main difference
uh and then i guess another difference
is instead of using a kernel machine for
the world model we could use a neural
net that in high dimension and the kinds
of problems we care about
usually works a lot better too
i have one question uh as you know the
the program confirms that ai aims to
develop methods tools in order to
to
have a sound deployment of ai in
critical systems
do you think that your approach is
could be suitable
in order to prepare and to design our
experimental plan
to do that
yeah i think there are a lot of
connections uh between safety issues and
and what i've talked about in fact i
mentioned you might want to go for a
setting like this precisely to
make sure you're going to in the end
take uh
decisions that that are safe
um
so uh so that's one aspect another
aspect is how you come up with the
uncertainty
uh the epistemic uncertainty right so uh
and and you need to actually
predict both the electronic uncertainty
and then the electricity and the
epistemic consumption so
uh there are techniques uh that we've
also written on uh in there uh you know
there's a whole literature on how you
could do that but now people are
starting to use
deep learning for for for these tasks
um
and
yeah it's it's very interesting like how
given a
a predictor
uh how do you estimate
uh how reliable it is
and so the the approach that we have
taken
is different from the bayesian approach
for reasons that would take you know too
much time to explain
but
when the model is misspecified the
vision approach might underestimate the
um the true error the true uncertainty
so uh what we do instead is we train a
second network that predicts the um
out of sample areas of the first one so
in other words uh and that's one method
there are other methods but but um
basically there's a rich
uh set of approaches to
just
get good estimate of
the uncertainty and that is important
for safety of course
um
so so yeah i think there are really
interesting connections between what i
talked about and what you've
mentioned okay this is bertrand again uh
i have a question on a different subject
because in your uh turing paper that was
that was published in acm in july
you talked about causal discovery
interventions
and today you also are talking about
causal discovery so i i will clearly see
that it's a
an important focus of your research for
a long time even so i just wonder how
close are you to really do cause of
different discovery on let's say rather
interesting or complex systems
right now we can do it on a small scale
like
a graph that has tens of variables or
maybe 100 variables or things like this
so we can't do it yet on the kind of
large scale that that are needed in many
applications but it's progressing pretty
quickly and i'm hoping that the
algorithm i mentioned today will help us
to move to the next uh scale
uh also up to now
the kind of causal graphs that we have
been doing uh discovery on our static so
in other words we assume that there is a
graph that's not too big that explains
how the world works like all the causal
variables and you know this one is the
cause of that one and so we're trying to
discover that graph
uh but the current techniques first of
all they don't learn the variables
themselves like they are assuming you
observe the causal variables but in the
real world often
what you get is like a video it's like
low-level stuff and you need to learn a
a mapping an encoder that goes from the
low-level stuff to the causal variable
so it's not the first problem we're
working on and the second problem is
that the graph the causal graph
um
may be uh dynamic so what i mean by this
um
if if i see so right now i'm i'm at home
and i'm looking in my garden and you
know i see a cat and a squirrel and the
cat may be chasing the squirrel
so here what i just did with my brain
is i came up with an explanation
for what is going on in in the in the
picture or in the video
and that explanation is at the level of
like causal relationships like you know
the cat is chasing the squirrel the
squirrel is climbing the tree
uh it's very abstract it doesn't contain
all the details but it contains the kind
of things that humans care about and
that we you know we're interested in for
reasoning and and
and taking decisions
um
and
what you notice about this
causal graph it's it's a it's a
you know it's different from
uh if i were to look at different uh
movie or a different video right so
there is a different causal graph
for each situation what do they have in
common
it's like the laws of physics they have
causal mechanisms to come so we're
trying to build extend the work that
we've done in the last years
so that we can
do causal discovery not of a fixed graph
but of the mechanisms that like think of
the laws of physics
um that explain everything that can
happen but then depending on the input
you will see different things happening
like
uh different uh events and different
um mechanisms are being involved like if
if a ball bounces on the wall there's
like a special mechanism for bouncing
that's happening there
but it doesn't always bounce no very
interesting in fact i think that uh even
a graph with
tens or the tens of hundreds of
variables with uh that you are able to
discover is really very uh is very rich
it's not a small one
uh i assume just to come to finish this
yeah because the classical work is like
two or three variables yes i assume just
for fit to finish this discussion that
you are not looking at uh loops in
causal graphs
you don't have feedback well
uh so so well we're thinking about it so
the causal graphs we've been working on
don't have loops there are directed
basically graphs
um but uh and if you i mean if you think
about time everything is directed you
see click
there is no going back in time
however the loops come up if you have a
dynamical system so think about
voltage and current and there are
abstractions and which one causes the
other i mean they both cause the other
right so it's kind of weird well if you
introduce time and you kind of think of
it like it's if i change the voltage now
it will change the current next so there
is there is an arrow of time and vice
versa so it's really like a dynamical
system and now if you think about it
uh in those terms as a like differential
equation or something like this
then you still have a proper uh sort of
causal framework
but um
the way to manage this computationally
is different you want to think about
like what's the fixed point of the
dynamics like
uh or things like this so it's it's a
different sort of set of mathematical
tools that we need
to hope to um to work with these uh
non-uh directed graphs that correspond
to
say fixed point of a dynamical system
thank you
the last question if there is
no i think that
thanks a lot uh joshua
the for the the talk and also for all
the this debate and the question and
answer session
again
[Applause]
you